so let's think about a function i'll
just give an example let's say h of n
is equal to
1 4
times
to the n
so first of all you might notice
something interesting here we have the
variable the input into our function
it's in the exponent and a function like
this is called an exponential function
so this is an exponential
exponential
exponential function and that's because
the variable the input into our function
is sitting in its definition of what is
the output of that function going to be
the input is in the exponent i can write
another exponential function
i could write f of let's say the input
is the variable t
is equal to
times
times 3
to the t once again this is an
exponential function
now there's a couple of interesting
things to think about an exponential
function in fact we'll explore many many
many of them but i'll get a little used
to the terminology so
one thing that you might see is the
notion of an initial value
initial
initial value and this is essentially
the value of the function when the input
is zero so for in these cases the
initial value for the function h is
going to be h of 0 and when we evaluate
that that's going to be 1 4 times 2 to
the 0 well 2 to the 0 power is just 1 so
it's equal to 1 4. so the initial value
at least in this case it seemed to just
be that number that sits out here we
have the initial value times some
some number to this exponent and we'll
come up with the name for this number as
well but let's see if this was true over
here for f of t so if we look at its
initial value
f of 0 is going to be 5 times 3 to the 0
power and the same thing again 3 to the
0 is just 1. 5 times 1 is just 5. so the
initial value is once again that so if
you have exponential functions of this
form it makes sense your initial value
well if you put a zero in for the
exponent then the the number raised to
exponents is going to be one and you're
going to be left with that thing that
you're multiplying by that hopefully
that makes sense but since you're
looking at it hopefully it does make a
little bit now you might be saying well
what do we call this number
what do we call that number there or
that number there
and that's called the common ratio
the common
common ratio
and in my brain we say well why is it
called why is it called a common ratio
well if you thought about integer inputs
into this especially sequential integer
in inputs into it you would see a
pattern for example
h of let me do this in that green color
h of 0 is equal to we already
established 1 4. now what is h of 1
going to be equal to it's going to be 1
4 times 2 to the first power so it's
going to be 1 4
times 2.
what is h of 2 going to be equal to
well it's going to be
1 4
times 2 squared so it's going to be
times 2 times 2
or we could just view this as
this is going to be 2 times
h of 1. and actually i should have done
this when i wrote this one out but this
we could write as 2 times h of 0. so
notice if we were to take the ratio
between h of 2 and h of 1 it would be 2.
if we were to take the ratio between h
of 1 and h of 0 it would be 2. that is
the common ratio between successive
whole number inputs into our function so
h of i could say
h of n plus 1 over
h of n
is going to be equal to
is going to be equal to actually i can
work it out mathematically 1 4 times 2
to the n plus 1
over 1 4 times 2 to the n
that cancels 2 to the n plus 1 divided
by 2 to the n is just going to be equal
to 2. that is your common ratio so for
for the function h for the function f
our common ratio is 3. if we were to go
the other way around if someone said hey
i have some function whose initial value
so let's say i have some function i'll
do some new color
i have some function g
and we know that it's initial
initial
value
is five
and someone were to say it's common
ratio
it's
common
ratio
is 6. what would this exponential
function look like and they're telling
you this is an exponential function
well g of let's say x is the input
is going to be equal to our initial
value which is 5
that's a that's not a negative sign
there our initial value is 5. all right
equals to make that clear
and then times our common ratio to the x
power so once again initial value right
over there that's the 5
and then our common ratio
is the 6
right over there so hopefully that gets
you a little bit familiar with some of
the the parts of an exponential function
why they are called what they are called